(audience cheers)
- Hello, nice to meet you.
Have y'all ever met?
Have you ever met Ana?
- No, it's our first time.
- Hi.
- [Kelly] Hello.
- [Phil] How's it going for you so far?
- Oh, so far it's going great.
- [Phil] Great.
- [Ana] Yes.
- [Phil] Good.
(all laugh)
- So you, and the Ted Lasso cast just went
to the White House.
Had you ever been there before?
Did you like it?
- Oh no.
It was fine.
- [Ana] It was cool?
- [Phil] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs and claps)
- [Phil] No, it was...
- [Kelly] I just love this photo.
That's a boss photo.
- [Phil] I don't know, man, I mean.
- Did you get a tour?
- We did get a tour, yeah.
- Okay.
- It's so funny, it's so silly.
Look at us all there.
Like, what are we doing there?
- Silly?
I think you look very cool.
- Thanks, man.
Yeah, no, it was a
total riot and also wild
because I don't know,
you see the Oval Office
so often in like TV shows and films.
You're like, "Is it real? Is this real?"
When you're in there, you're like,
"This is the real one, right?"
- No, I've been in it and it's crazy.
You feel, yeah, like you're in ...
- [Phil] The whole thing was surreal.
- ... the West Wing.
- [Phil] Yeah.
- Yeah.
So in the show we get, Ted brings ...
- [Kelly] Biscuits.
- The biscuits.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And they very kindly gave us this
little box of biscuits with
a president of the
United States seal on it.
- Oh, that's cool.
- That's cute.
- Very cool.
I was like, "Can I have another
one for my dad, please?"
(audience laughs)
- That's thoughtful.
- Yeah, it was good.
- I love a thoughtful gift.
You grew up in DC, right?
- I did, yeah.
- [Kelly] Did you go to the White House?
- I did as a kid because I
was a childhood friend of
Amy Carter's in the Carter White House
- [Kelly] Which is just so random.
- Yeah, and when you go
like the cam, I mean, again,
even then which was the,
you know, analog '70s,
it, you know, you would go
like for the weekend, you know,
and you would come back and
like, I have a photograph
of Amy and President Carter
and myself tobogganing.
And you never saw the photographers,
would just like show up at the house.
So crazy.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah, crazy.
- We didn't ...
- You didn't get to toboggan, huh?
- We tobogganed, yeah, yeah.
- You did?
- We did.
It's got these kind of stairs.
- I never got that experience on a ...
- It's a little strange
'cause it was like a
childhood accident, you know?
I mean, we were in a program.
- [Kelly] I know, that's so cool though.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] To have that memory.
- Well you, Phil, you play
a soccer star in Ted Lasso.
- Yes, yeah, I dunno
what I'm doing actually.
- But you also play,
you play soccer in real
life though too, right?
- I do, I do.
- Yeah, have you always loved playing,
football where you're from?
- Thank you, yes.
(audience laughs)
- Yes, yes.
Obviously not football
where we're from, but yes,
football where you're from, yes.
- Foot ball.
(audience laughs)
- Here's the thing, here's
the thing, I get it, I know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Why do they call it a parkway and
why do they call it a driveway?
I'm just saying like, it's,
you should call them the
opposite, I'm just saying.
Anyway, so yeah, so yeah.
So you play soccer in real life?
- I do, yes.
And not at all anywhere
near as well as Jamie does.
I'm a sort of enthusiastic,
sort of sweaty box-to-box midfielder,
rather than having any sort
of panache or style with it,
but it's kind of, it,
since the show has come out,
it's been a sort of double edged sword
in the sense that I think
there's been a couple of times
where I've finished a game and
someone will come up to me afterwards
and I'm like, sweating, really sweating
and like really embarrassed
myself a couple of times.
Like miss the ball and
it's gone out, whatever.
And now as somebody...
- And you play a soccer star.
- Yeah, literally.
(audience laughs)
- Did they call you out for that?
- [Phil] Sky was like ...
- "Great job, Jamie."
- Literally, he was like,
"Don't you play Jamie Tartt on Ted Lasso?"
(all laugh)
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
- [Kelly] "I'm just having an off day."
- Yeah.
But they have really great
editors that make us look
like we know what we're doing.
And it's, it's just like, it's a really,
like it's like a dance really.
It's like choreography more than it is
actually playing football
because you've gotta, you know,
you've gotta hit, you know,
you've gotta hit your
mark as you would normally
when you're acting.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That sounds so stressful.
- It's stressful, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's just working out to us.
- [Ana] Yeah.
(all laugh)
- I love that you pointed
out though, editors,
like editors never get
the credit they deserve
because they make you look so good.
(everyone claps)
Like in, I just got into TV world.
- Yeah.
- Like, I mean, I obviously
started in TV world
but I didn't really get it until now.
And like, on "The Voice",
whether it's this show
or anything you see, it's just
like the editors really are
the magic makers I feel
like, they're so key.
Is it true that you're also
a video game character now?
I mean, I think you've made it
when you're a video game game character.
- Yeah.
- You've arrived.
- I'm just saying.
(audience applauds)
- This is my last public
appearance, this is it.
(audience applauds)
- This is my real question.
And you have to be,
(audience cheers)
you have to be honest.
Have you ever played yourself in the game?
Like you're ...
- Yes.
- Okay!
I was like...
(audience applauds)
"Guy, I would play me."
I'd be like, "I'm killing it."
- He's also really good as well,
so he's like, he's,
I just give the ball to him all the time.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
- There was a time when my
girlfriend came back home,
and I mean, it puts a whole
different meaning to her
finding you playing with
yourself but it's with myself.
(all laugh)
And she came ...
- So your girlfriend came in.
- She was like, "Not again."
(all laugh)
Yeah, it's, rather embarrassing.
- Oh my, it's nothing worse
than that bust, I mean.
(all laugh and clap)
- [Kelly] I love this man though.
- Nothing worse.
I mean, my children have
caught me watching old sketches
of mine howling and laughing
at myself, nothing ...
- The good old, the good days.
- [Ana] It's humiliating.
- Oh my God, it's awesome.
- I still watch it, but
I'm like, "Start it over."
- "No wait, you missed this part."
- Yeah, yeah.
"Look, come watch this,
this is the best bit."
Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.